all good things must come to an end and
if you're finishing up your time in
eldon ring and want another huge
challenging game to tackle afterwards
then this is the video for you here are
12 ish games to check out if you want to
scratch that elden ring itch
[Music]
surprise i know but i'm just getting
them out of the way while games like
dark souls and bloodborne have long been
heralded as some of the best gaming has
to offer not everyone has played them
and that's okay if you've bested the
lands between now's a perfect time to go
back and see how from software evolved
its approach to design over time to
create arguably one of the best games
ever made you might even see some
familiar faces if you really liked eldon
ring's gameplay systems and take on dark
fantasy you can't go wrong with demon
souls and the dark souls trilogy
especially dark souls 3 and its dlc's if
you really vibed with a magic build in
elden ring definitely try it out in
demon souls but sword and board is just
as rewarding the souls games share a lot
of the elden ring dna the leveling
system will feel immediately familiar as
will the more hands-off approach to
storytelling and the game's
interconnected level design you might
just have to get used to weapon
degradation though sorry but if more
aggressive gameplay is your style then
bloodborne and sakura shadows die twice
are for you bloodborne encourages more
aggressive play by giving you a window
to regain health once you've been hit
but only if you hit your attacker
instead of shying away while all games
rely on timing sakura is the one that
requires perhaps the most precise timing
of them all with critical strikes at key
moments crucial to break the poise of
even the toughest of enemies no matter
which you choose the risk versus reward
tension you feel when moving forward in
elden ring is in every single one of the
games of course so is the difficulty
which is especially true in the offline
second row as you are not able to summon
help
bet you didn't see this one coming
either the legend of zelda breath of the
wild redefined open worlds and its
influence on elden ring is readily
apparent especially with the pin system
you can use to make your own landmarks
on the map for exploration later it's
far easier than eldon ring and isn't a
souls-like at all but it's filled to the
brim with secrets you find completely
organically giving you a sense of
discovery that just isn't possible in
more guided open world games
while there are huge sheikah towers to
climb that unfog part of the map what
they don't do is mark every explorable
location for you you need to go find
stuff yourself cheese is also on the
menu just like in eldon ring so you can
literally jump over certain sections of
the map if you have the know-how breath
of the wild also has a pretty fantastic
and active speed running community and
it's really fun to see the wild ways
people can play this game
deck 13 took a backstab at the soul's
formula with lords of the fallen in 2014
and
it was not very successful lifting some
of the series aesthetic elements without
really understanding the structure the
surge and especially its superior sequel
did not make that mistake set in a city
torn apart by chaos after a major
technological disaster it trades fantasy
for science fiction you battle with
repurposed construction tools like
hammers and saws alongside more advanced
technology all the while upgrading your
gear unlocking doors and elevators and
battling powerful bosses it isn't just a
reskinned take on souls however with a
unique dismemberment system letting you
choose which body part to focus on and
sever during a battle in order to
acquire armor parts or weapons
lovely
just like terminator 2 and paddington 2
before it neo 2 is one of those sequels
that is just better than the original
neo2 doesn't feature an open world like
elden ring instead using a series of
discrete levels with interconnected
segments a lost grace equivalent is here
as well as is the currency you drop upon
death and used to level up your
character neo2 also offers more
incentive for combat experimentation
than eldon ring as you don't need to
bolster weapons to make them effective
instead you'll find new ones constantly
and can try them out for a change of
pace doing so can make even the hardest
bosses seem more manageable as does the
new burst counter move which lets you
quickly turn the tables and aggressively
attack your enemy ps5 owners can pick up
the neo collection which includes
remastered versions of both neo games
almost every soul style game uses a
melee combat system which makes sense
given how much time you spend memorizing
boss's attack patterns so that you can
dodge them but gunfire games made a bold
decision with remnant from the ashes
it's a combined souls-like and
third-person shooter and it somehow
succeeds at both post-apocalyptic
settings aren't exactly in short supply
these days but remnant's nature-centric
take on the concept help it to stand out
as does the extensive cooperative
support if you're looking for a huge
world stuffed full of secrets to uncover
well look elsewhere but remnant from the
ash's combat should feel like a creative
riff on existing ideas after playing
elden ring
before star wars jedi fallen order
released the thought of a soul-style
game set in a galaxy far far away didn't
seem to make much sense but respawn
managed to make it work by lifting key
elements from several other games too
the world and spectacle are classic
uncharted but anyone who uses a melee
weapon and likes to counter-attack in
elden ring will pick up fallen orders
combat very quickly it's not as sharp
and as punishing as sakuro since you're
given a fair amount of freedom in how
you tackle each encounter even down to
splitting your lightsaber in two or
rocking a double-sided darth maul blade
but if you've played elden ring and you
have the twin blade on your mind it's
worth a shot in a few ways assassin's
creed odyssey is the opposite of elden
ring its ui is busier pointing you more
explicitly towards objectives and the
open world isn't really designed to be
explored at will however the combat
system delivers the defend punish defend
loop elden ring does so well albeit with
more customization via skill trees for
special abilities that loop already
etched into your brain from hours of
battling tough bosses in elden ring will
be instantly familiar to you even the
stealth bears some resemblance to elden
ring as it's often used to take out one
or two targets before going into an
all-out brawl that's a far cry from the
stealth heavy assassin's creed games of
old
love elden ring but wish it was a goth
anime well you're in luck as that's
exactly what code vein is set in a world
overrun with vampiric creatures code
vein's action is absolutely bonkers with
swords axes hammers and more available
alongside very special vampire abilities
called gifts they truly make you feel
like the ultimate vampire warrior and
every swing of your weapon just feels
fantastic as a bonus one of the late
game areas bears a striking resemblance
to anor londo from dark souls so it's
got that going for it
a decidedly on triple a take on the from
software formula that still understands
its essence ashen is a strange game it
features some ludicrously difficult
bosses a bonfire-like checkpoint system
and tons of secrets across its desolate
landscapes but it also oozes a sense of
calm you don't have to worry about
something attacking you absolutely
everywhere giving you an opportunity to
explore the gorgeous open world that has
a minimalist art style a technical
showcase this is not but it's impressive
nonetheless
the witcher 3 makes our list of games
like eldon ring for its world rather
than its combat or any souls-like
mechanics geralt's journey takes him
across a staggeringly large area varied
and full of deadly creatures as well as
npcs who need some problems solved
exploration plays a major role in fully
enjoying the witcher 3 a cd projekt red
put an enormous amount of care into
making sure that nothing feels like
filler content you're also able to get
advantages against certain enemies by
making use of the right potions and for
anyone struggling with a particular boss
in elden ring that maybe this'll work
approach will be very familiar
horizon forbidden west is similar to
other aaa open world games in terms of
its ui and handholding as you get quest
journals and lots of other progress
tracking features that are not in elden
ring however the experience can also be
very emergent as aloy stumbles across
enormous dungeons called cauldrons that
can take a big chunk of time to complete
elden ring players will be familiar with
this sort of side tracking loop as the
game routinely sends you toward an
objective while distracting you with
caves and tunnels to explore instead
if breath of the wild was one source of
inspiration for elden rings world design
the elder scrolls 5 skyrim was certainly
another its do anything approach rewards
you for venturing into the unknown to
discover dungeons treasure and quests
and though it certainly lacks the
difficulty of elden ring it offers a
similar level of flexibility and
personalization in the combat if you
want to go in as a stealthy bow equipped
assassin it's cliche but you can or you
can attack with a frontal assault using
a sword and shield with no set classes
you can mix and match rocking a fire
spell in one hand while bashing enemies
skulls in with a club in the other it
released 10 years ago and still feels so
great to play plus it's on pretty much
everything at this point so there's
really no excuse
while nothing will truly fill the hole
that eldon ring has left in our hearts
hopefully there'll be a few things on
this list that you'll enjoy until
miyazaki and the team at from software
magic up another game for more on eldon
ring make sure to subscribe to gamespot
i'm on twitter at lucy james games and
i'll catch you next time
and